good morning Hank it's Tuesday I had a
great weekend in fact I'm probably
experiencing peak happiness right now so
listen I don't believe in listening to
my gut I find my gut to be unreliable on
many levels
sorry about my voice by the way I've
been screaming for four days but yeah
when you live with an illness of
disordered thinking as I do you have to
learn not to trust your intuition
because it's constantly lying to you to
cite a minor example from my own life my
intuition tells me many times a day that
I did not lock the car door when in fact
I always lock the car door I bring this
up because on Saturday morning my
unreliable gut told me that in order for
the soccer team I've loved for most of
my life to win the Champions League I
needed to give away one of my most
prized possessions a jersey signed by
former Liverpool captain Steven Gerrard
now this is the part of the video where
I tell you that of course I understand
that giving away a signed jersey is not
going to affect the outcome of a
sporting event that's happening
thousands of miles away but no no I
don't understand that
I mean I get it intellectually I guess
but one like a lot of humans I'm
incurably superstitious and - Who am I
to say why we won the Champions League
but I think something else might have
also been going on which is that lately
I've been thinking a lot about the verb
to treasure and how valuing something
can sometimes lead to hoarding it when
what would help the universe most might
be to share what you value rather than
clinging to it like that Jersey had
brought me a lot of joy and maybe it was
time for it to bring someone else joy
right so I was in New York City for book
on that day I walked into a soccer bar
found a guy sitting alone wearing a
Liverpool shirt who appeared to be
approximately a size L and I told him
that I'd had a premonition that I needed
to give away this signed jersey and I
gave it to him he was a nice guy with a
PhD and I think something science he he
didn't know who I was but he was very
excited about the Jersey so we chatted
for a bit took a picture together and
then I left he told me his name but I
don't remember it I'm not gonna show his
face because I don't know if he wants
his face shown but if anybody happens to
know this guy I'd love to know how his
day went due primarily to me giving away
this Jersey and secondarily to the
exploits of the players on the field
Liverpool won the game to nil I was
actually backstage at bookcon during the
last couple minutes of the game and
Kristine fro Seth who plays Alaska in
the Looking for Alaska hula show got
this video of me very nervous and
excited after the game Akilah Hughes and
I went to a Liverpool bar in the
neighborhood and sang our heart
sout and everyone was hugging everyone
at one point in the evening I was
hugging a stranger which is not
something I do in the normal course of
daily events and I noticed that he was
crying he was heaving sobs and I didn't
understand why he was crying until I
found that I was also crying and then I
knew why sports are about winning and
losing heartbreak and joy grief and
celebration they provide simple
narratives when life only provides
complicated ones but more than that I
think they are about celebrating
together and grieving together and being
together sports remind us that what we
have is not as important as what we
share and that we are never truly alone
not in loss and not in victory at the
end of every game Liverpool fans sing a
song that ends walk on walk on with hope
in your heart and you'll never walk
alone my wish is that each of us might
always know that truth as profoundly as
I did on Saturday night whether you love
football or not you'll never walk alone
Hank I'll see you on Friday
hi